[Music]
hey
yes sir howard doss we're still here at
crown con man we are still at crime con
having a great time um
sounds repetitive man las vegas having a
great time
amazing
group of people that have shown up for
this thing and we've been really
fortunate not just talking to people
about the podcast of course the
questions about live pd
but we've come across some people with
some amazing stories absolutely
i've got an amazing story for you okay
let's you well you and i know how
important family is right absolutely our
kids our parents
we've lived
we've been kind of i guess i hate to use
this term but i'm going to do it anyway
we have been fortunate enough or blessed
enough to have great parents that is
true so imagine you're a kid you're like
i don't know
pre-pubescent maybe 11 12 years old and
you find out that your mom's dead
horrible absolutely horrible and then
but worse than that you've
you know
that
your dad killed her
unimaginable but nobody believes you
that's our story today our guest is
collier landry call your glad to have
you glad to be here guys glad to be glad
to uh glad to have you here so
obviously quite the story we'll get in
and chat with um
it just i'm going to bring it up to
speed on how we even got to have you
here this was not a plan deal until less
than 24 hours ago
you know we had guests lined up that we
were going to talk to while we were here
at crime con
and you had just uh i'd seen you man
listen and i mean this in the best way
you kind of stand out walking around
here at crime con and you know there are
a lot of uh a lot of a lot of females
here at this thing so even just there's
there's not as many males and you're
kind of a and howard just billed whiskey
all over the table um but you know
you're uh you're a bigger guy you've got
the you know how to you got the longer
hair you've had pulled back in the
ponytail you know you've got this little
la vibe swag to you uh with your jewelry
the tattoos you know the stuff that that
you know you made you stand out in the
crowd and i mean that in the best way
you do i mean for for other guys to even
you know take notice of you i mean that
in the best way but you had ventured
over to our table there and i think you
started talking with howard first and
one of the other ladies that was working
our table and i was ventured off doing
something else and came back over and
i'd seen you you know over the weekend
and then and here you were at our table
and howard's like man this guy's got a
story hell yeah he's got a story he
started so well who was the guy you were
with that came up and introduced you
uh stephen cohen so he's with uh
um
chris hansen yeah and i interviewed
chris on my podcast like last week
um
and we he saw
me in the new york post in like february
they did an article about the podcast
and then he hit me up on linkedin and so
that's how i met him and it's the first
time i've actually met him in person
i've talked to him much on the phone but
um and then he was like and i i swore he
told me about your podcast but he didn't
but he's holding up these guys like from
the midwest or like a little west of the
midwest and they they drink whiskey and
they and they talk about like
true crime and i was like oh this must
be the guys but then it wasn't but he
was like well i don't know what i was
talking about i was like whatever well
you're super cool we are the guys we are
the guys whoever else he was talking
about yeah those are like the little
brothers man we are the guys the guys
look like the guys they look like the
guys they're right in the middle here
they've got to be the guys but then you
should have seen our in-person podcast
it was huge yeah they did well it did
well well i saw you guys on stage and i
was like wondering i was like who are
they they're drinking whiskey these guys
and they were and people were interested
and i'm like and i hear the accents and
i'm kind of like oh those are my people
but yeah what are they doing here and
then you know uh you were holding the
court on the left side of the table yeah
and then you were in the middle
and i'm like okay so he looks like i
literally thought i'm like he looks like
the cop like the the ex-fed but i don't
know i mean i don't i'm just looking i
don't even know who you are and then i'm
like you look like the producer and then
there was another guy who was on the
right i can't remember him but i
remembered you two yeah and i was like
oh this looks like this looks like a
little little racket they got going on
it's pretty cool yeah it worked yeah
that was gil carrillo that we had up
there he was actually a retired uh la
county sheriff's oh right a department
homicide guy he was one of the guys that
kind of busted the uh
the nightstalker case oh that's so
that's who he was that's his uh you know
he investigated hundreds i think what he
say seven eight hundred murders during
his time there in l.a county that was we
got him liquored up we did we got him
he's a wine guy we got him drinking
whiskey up we're giving some barrel
proof uh bourbon he got a little he's
like
got a little buzz at the end but we like
to drink on here we do and we're going
to continue with drinking some old dough
yes we are we are drinking that old elk
that's got our cocktails and cocktails
logo on it with a pretty little
character picture of it quite a bit yeah
and half the bottle spilled on the table
now so i guess you could probably like
put this up and just suck it out of
there like a survival tactic you know
those survival tactics like when you're
lost in the desert you can you know soak
the moisture up through clothing or
something jason's are our
outdoorsman here does that sound right
jason yeah jason says it would work so i
could sit back on your dirty t-shirt so
any of you guys get lost in the desert
take whiskey spill it into
a terrible looking
table cover from bally's you could
survive
all right but so anyway so oh he's not
drinking that collier's not drinking man
oh i quit drinking during the pandemic
but i am going to do my little cbd thc
combo edibles and join you guys that's
your thing going man
we've had a guy that uh we we've
interviewed before uh that that smoked
blunts during the whole time
he was smoking blood so this is but
we've never had anybody hit the gummy so
man this is a first right here but going
back to you know talking with collier
there at the when i walked up
um you know it just kind of says hey
those are beautiful by the way yeah it's
like cool little little pat i mean this
is california yeah it's california it's
just you know it's like they do spark it
into kids that's candy dude
hey what's that you're just a big kid
man california's real progressive they
want to get all the kids on the weed
but
they want to get everybody on the weed
the weed okay so as we were saying so
you know just says hey you know i think
your exact words were my father killed
my mom
and uh
you know i was a cop for 25 years and
unfortunately i've been on those type of
scenes and have heard these things and i
was like okay and
um then you
and obviously during here in the podcast
we'll go into the full details but you
start laying out some of the details
and
i don't know 30 seconds into it
i'm like wait a minute i i think i know
this story and as you continue on
uh i think howard drops that your father
was a doctor
and again i'm not giving anything away
ahead of time but the show forensic
files yeah which i had never watched
until within the past year first time i
started watching it and as you
just i mean literally briefly are kind
of laying out some just little
bits from the story
i'm like was this a forensic files and
you're like yes that's me i was the kid
that testified in this and i'm just like
holy shit one of the handful of episodes
i have ever seen
happens to be this one and uh
i don't want to call it
a fluke deal but just the fact that here
we are talking a a show i just watched
recently serendipitous
well the episode is called foundation of
lies and it lies and it's like top 10 in
forensic files i'm actually in the book
that's coming out about forensic files
later on this year they interviewed me
because i'm just like what like this is
like a really popular episode but i told
you i had a funny story about that
because you said you were watching it
with your girlfriend or your wife
yeah my wife yes and you just happened
to see it and i saw the episode i've
never actually seen the whole episode
but
i was on a date
in 2004 in l.a i go over this girl's
house
and
gorgeous girl and we're flipping through
the channels sitting on our couch you
know after you know post-coital i guess
whatever and she's like uh you know
flipping through and there's me on the
witness stand and i see it and i'm just
like oh shit does she recognize you as a
kid
flips through
past and she goes
and she stops and she looks over at me
and then she flips the channel back
about three channels and looks and i'm
just like
hey cause i got these blue eyes so it's
weird oh you did a mistake and there's
two of them and there's two of them and
they're like and i'm on the witnessing
like
you know as the picture that i showed
you guys
and i was just like yeah and the thing
is is when i moved to los angeles like i
left my small town of mansfield ohio i
was 18 i went to music school i dropped
out of music school after about two and
a half years and i moved to the west
coast i moved to l.a because i wanted
you know no money you know just like i'm
gonna go start off in a new place with
uh where the talent oh sorry where the
talent goes right where you gotta be
like cream of the you know cream of the
crop and i'm gonna go try to make it
where nobody's gonna know a fucking
thing about my story because the biggest
thing for me can i curse on this
you can cuss all these fantastic because
it's very hard for me you're doing
fucking gummies on here man
there we go
i don't i've never cheers the gummy
before that's quite interesting
my liquid tablecloth now so i um
i go uh
you know i was like i don't want to
leave
the problem is growing up in a small
town where this happens and you're it's
it was just like the largest
this is definitely the largest criminal
case in central ohio history sure but it
was also like the second largest murder
trial in ohio history period behind the
dr sam shepard case which was made into
the movie the fugitive by the way
starring harrison ford yes um tommy lee
jones anyways um okay you know i'm a
movie guy
i work in the business so i gotta you
know i gotta say
there's a nice low fill coming from
overhead i love all this um
but
i was like i don't i wanna i don't want
people to know my story because they did
and everybody like walking in the room
or you know in ohio oh that's the guy
that's the kid and that's a lot to deal
with so i was like i'm gonna come out to
a place where nobody knows the fuck who
i am and over the years is working
i
people knew basically the the basics
okay yeah i call your my dad killed my
mom when i was a kid that's it like i
never really got into it and i mean i'm
talking like girls i dated for i dated a
girl for six years you know she knew a
little bit about the story but we never
really got into it because it was like i
didn't really i wanted people to
discover who i am
and i had seen a movie called american
history acts in 1999.
top five of all time fantastic movies
one of the veer off yeah ed norton just
amazing it's one of those deals that you
know uh
i watched it growing up you know type of
deal when it came back out
and when my kids got to the age where i
thought it was appropriate for them to
watch i made them watch it just because
i've seen this it's one of the most
well-known scenes in all of uh you know
the film industry i think that curb
stream it really is sorry fantastic
movie that film and i was like whoever
made that film
understands the consequences of violence
because i
from age 11 on was absolutely and now
like i was think i was saying yesterday
and i tell people it's very in fashion
to like care about victims and oh what's
going on we're very empathetic and we
all that that wasn't the case 25 years
ago how old are you now i'm 44. okay so
i'm actually literally the age that my
mother was when she was murdered so that
was a big deal turning 44 a couple
months ago and also today may 1st 2022
is my father's 79th birthday and he is
still incarcerated
will he be there forever
i don't know okay he's up for parole
again in like three years all right well
we'll get into that in a second but i
see this film american history actually
go whoever did this
understands the consequences of violence
because i am passionate about like look
it's judge you know
baga goes to jail victim is dead gavel
hits state gets his restitution and we
say next we never look at the
consequence of violence the ancillary
victims the non-combat ptsd we never
examined that i was very passionate
about that so i was like this person
gets this flash forward 10 years later
i'm at my place in hollywood my
girlfriend comes into the time she goes
this guy wants to photograph me for a
coffee table book he's a movie producer
she was a model obviously and it's like
you know um
um but so
she says you know he's done a bunch of
movies i was like okay what are they and
she's like booty call 11 14. have a shit
starts naming all these movies and she
says american history i said american
history x and she goes yeah let's get
him over our house so me the dude would
become friends his name is john
morrissey
and
a couple years later he and i are
talking and he's like he wanted to do
some sort of silly project i was like
what you need to do is this project that
i have and i was like i want to do i
want to do a docu-series about the
consequences of violence in america
and examine all these things that we
don't look at and here's the best news i
own the rights to the pilot and i gave
him a book of all these newspaper
articles that were collected from me as
a kid that somebody gave to me when i
was 18
about the whole case from when my mother
went missing to where my father was
convicted for like his first like to
turn of the millennium you know all this
stuff his parole looking back on the
case all this all these things
and he's just like he read it and he
called me next day he goes are you
fucking shitting me this is you
this is you like i didn't know this and
i was like well yeah i was like nobody
knows this like and he goes i have a he
know i have a friend who i just did a a
feature film with with like
channing tatum and joey gordon-levitt
and hathaway and but she's a documentary
filmmaker she's won two academy awards i
bet you should be interested in this
and then over the next five six seven
years we developed what is now known on
investigation discovery as a murder in
mansfield
wow
well let's talk about a murder in
mansfield yeah let's talk about that day
that all this started yeah so when i was
11 years old on new year's eve 1989 i
awoke in the middle of the night to like
the sound of two loud thuds and like a
scream
so
the scream is what woke me up and then i
heard these thuds like and they were
about like 60 to 90 seconds apart and
then i hear my father muttering or some
a male voice muttering
i'm terrified laying in the bed i'm
looking at my batman clock on the wall
and it says like 3 18 a.m and i'm
i'm laying there and i hear these
footsteps like slowly walk down the hall
and as a child i slept with my door open
and i'm laying like this for those that
are watching this and i'm can see out of
my peripheral vision and i see these
footsteps these two feet in my doorway
and i'm just like
what's going on don't
look
up
because
you know now i realize that if i looked
up
look it's um it's not difficult to just
make the hole a little bit bigger
but i wouldn't be here today
no fucking way
and
the footsteps left
i went back to sleep
i woke up like
super early that morning i ran to my
mother's bedroom i started scavenging
the seat sheets looking for blood all
this stuff the bed's a mess and i'm just
like what is going on i come downstairs
my father is sitting on the couch
wrapped in a towel you're just taking a
shower
i said where is my mother
and he looks at me and goes well collier
mommy took a little vacation
mommy took a little vacation collier
and then he proceeds to launch into this
whole you know
and i'm like i of course do not believe
him
sure and
um
because my mother had never left me
before so i was always her constant
companion and they were going through a
divorce he had a mistress who was
pregnant which i didn't know at the time
she was pregnant but and that's what i
was getting sorry to cut you off there
that's going to ask
leading up until that night
you know were there fights between your
mom and dad you know whether it be
physical or just heavy arguments you
know that you were hearing stuff like
that
so my father was always very abusive and
he had a great one of those raging
tempers like to just
boom go off on a split second
um but my father was not around a lot he
was a doctor he worked a lot
um and as i came to find out he had he
all these girlfriends so he was leading
like these dual lives
um and i hardly ever saw my dad i would
sometimes like our bonding thing was i
would go with him to make his rounds to
the hospital which i loved doing i loved
talking i would go and sing and tap
dance for the the patients and all this
stuff i was a little performer
and
i would um you know go skiing with him
on ski trips but even then he would like
be like oh i'll come back to the room
and then just disappear and like you
know i received someone i'd be like
what's going on
um as i started getting older right
that was really the extent of our
relationship but other than that he was
really abusive to me all right
yeah go ahead i'm going to be a nursing
profiler here because i'm a nurse and i
know what type of doctor was he he was
an osteopath
so like i guess that's like a gp yeah so
okay yeah those guys do kind of flop
they handle a lot
they're they're less important than they
think they should be and so they get a
little bit pissed off whenever you kind
of like you just pat them on the head
and keep you just pat them on the head
and they keep going
true power everybody knows this the true
power in hospital this is nurses the
nurses the male nurses yeah absolutely
there's three of us that are bald three
of us in the nation yeah that's it
that's all we control all of it we can
call ourselves to try it you're gonna be
nice to we gotta be nice to the uh the
triad yeah that's right yeah that'll get
you okay go ahead sorry about it it's
all good um so
yeah he was very violent growing up you
know
he would strike me with the bell things
like that but he just had this like fly
off the handle and the only time my
mother left me she went to china because
we're in taiwan because
my parents had adopted about six months
before she was murdered a little girl
from taiwan
and
um
they
when my father when my mother was gone
because i couldn't travel because i was
heavily asthmatic and i got really sick
before we were supposed to leave and i
would have died on the airplane for sure
um so they went my father wouldn't let
me go
and
while my mother was gone for like
whatever was ten days he was super
abusive to me he chased me around the
house call me a stupid little fat boy
because i was heavy as a kid because i
was taking steroids for asthma and stuff
and i wasn't able to like i was like
oh yeah it was bad it was like it
happened i got i developed like really
bad asthma i was like nine or ten and
then it just i was 11 at the time and he
would just chase me around and throw
things at me and scream at me and he was
just so horrible then he would just calm
down i'm so sorry or whatever oh my god
like he was a nightmare i'm sorry i was
terrified of my father
but on that morning i'm looking at him
i'm like you motherfucker you know i
knew
straight away so he left he he launches
in his whole diatribe about like we're
not going to call the police we're not
going to call the fbi and i'm like as
soon as he said the fbi i'm like
like i'm literally thinking about it who
says that like who this who the fuck
says that we're in mansfield ohio the
fbi yeah they're gonna come down here
and send james bond is coming too right
right ridiculous
and i'm like okay something's fishy am i
he had brought his mother
the night before um which she was really
close to my mother like they were like
best friends
and then so she was gonna apparently
watch us right my sister and i
and so my father leaves i had tucked
phone numbers underneath this garfield
that i had this little
santa garfield
and i called my mother's friends and i
said look i told them what happened i
said you need to call the police
and so they did
two uniform officers came out to the
house
asked a couple of questions i told them
what happened my grandmother was like
following me which is super weird and it
was like i couldn't say anything because
she was gonna replace when my father
left she's like okay you heard your
father we're not gonna do this we're not
gonna i'm just like what the fuck is
going on like why aren't you concerned
that my mother is missing like you're
you love my mother this isn't normal
this is not normal red flags everywhere
and
i um
i
they came out and i was like they're not
buying my story
what happened is is the next day i'm
like calling the friends like what like
what's happening was oh it's a missing
person's case i'm like that's bullshit
like somebody needs to get here like
she's not missing guys she's dead
like she's fucking dead right and
you know everybody's confused and you
know but what happened was is this one
detective named david messmore
had seen the missing persons case and
like look it was like new year's day
1990 so there's not a lot going on you
know it's a small town it's not like
it's la where there's a bunch of shit
happening
and he saw this he goes oh doctor's
wife's missing huh and he just decided
to come out to the house
yeah was your mom
you know obviously your father being a
doctor probably did financially decently
well was she a stay-home mom she was a
stay-at-home mom she did his books you
know i never knew
the extent that my mother put my father
through medical school she took care of
the family well before we were family
but like she had a great job because she
graduated from the university of
pennsylvania
school of dentistry was a dental
hygienist making 25 an hour in the 1960s
in philadelphia like that's a lot of
money yeah back then absolutely you know
um so she was able to support him which
i found out when i was making the
documentary anyways um
so messmore comes out and my grandmother
refuses to let him in the door or
whatever blah blah blah i'm like come on
come on in buddy
and you know i'm a lot faster than a
seven-year-old woman i would hope so and
i grab him and i pull him aside and
she's like tending to my sister or
something and i'm like
don't like my mother is dead
this is what happened
and he's just like
and what ended up happening is
i went to school the next day
um you know going back to like january
2nd or whatever and i told the principal
at the school i said you need to call
down at the mansfield police department
ask for this guy named lieutenant david
messmore
you need to get very specific you need
to get him here
he came to my school
and i was you know and that was my
safety zone because my father was i was
away from my father i was in school you
know and he
um and i couldn't i didn't have to worry
about all of that
so i developed this rapport with dave
messmore he would come to school and i'd
be like and i told him the first day i
was like i'm going to go home tonight
i'm going to run upstairs and i'm going
to pull the bookcases out of the wall
the shelves and look behind them and see
if i can find my mother's body i'm
almost i'm not even 12 years old this
time these are the conversations i'm
having with this man i'm like i know she
would if she was going to leave she
would take this purse and she would
bring this i'm going to see if that
person is in the house i'm going to be
like and this is like
like who is this kid
i need to get him here like every day
i'm i'm like wanting to talk to him like
what happens what do you know what do
you this and
i i unbeknownst to me like he was
catching shit from his captain
because he's like okay you're now
investigating a doctor
in our small town we don't do that like
they got into a fight she left he goes
yeah but there's something about this
kid like this kid this kid won't leave
me alone yeah he's at him like he's like
this and he's sharp he's not he's not
like a dumb kid he's
like he's so astute and he's got these
blue eyes that just suck me in and
there's two of them there's two of them
um and what happened is is my father was
traveling back and forth to erie
pennsylvania because he was going to
start his new life there and a new
practice focusing in um occupational
medicine like workman's comp
um
i'm with my father this is mid-january
1990.
my father goes into the gas station
to pay for
gas i see him in the thing i open up the
console and i'm rummaging through his
truck while watching him and i find two
polaroid photographs one is of a house
and the other one is of his girlfriend
with her two kids sitting in front of a
fireplace that was covered in plastic so
it struck me as being like a new
fireplace now
carly let me ask you this at this point
you find these photos
did you know your dad was you know had a
girlfriend was this something that
discussions arguments in the house you'd
met her before i had met his girl so i
had met his girlfriend the year previous
um uh at memorial day and he told me he
was a patient and then on father's day
of 1989
we met up with her and she gave us these
remote control cars and oh she happened
to show up at the suntan place and oh
look who's here it's sherry i mean i
even say this in the trial
control cars are cool though
and so she gives us these remote control
cars and then
um my father asked me to lie to my
mother about it and what happened was i
saw him tongue kiss this woman and i'm
like well that's not a friendly kiss
that was 11.
that's not a friendly friend of the
family kiss type thing and she had a
ring on that my i recognized in my
mother's i said oh my mommy has a ring
like that and she just kind of giggled
or whatever
and
it wasn't until that next day we went
out that night i got really sick
the next morning i was playing with a
radio control car in the driveway and i
was i felt so guilty i came in i sat by
my i said i said mommy i need you to sit
down i said i i think
daddy asked me to lie to you i think
daddy has a girlfriend and she said you
know i don't appreciate you lying to me
but i do appreciate you telling me the
truth and becoming honest about how you
got the remote control car
and then she went inside and i think she
called my father and was like that's it
because they unbeknownst to me had an
agreement she knew about all the affairs
she even knew about this girlfriend and
that she was pregnant she was like the
moment you involve our son is fucking
done like that's it you cross the line
in the sand we're done and my father
being a narcissist and a sociopath
like that was the lie and the same for
him and he's like no and i guess a lot
of the discussions were is like you know
you're coming to erie with me one way or
another and so when my father would be
at the house there were these very
there's arguments and things like that
but he's pretty much stayed away
now
during this time so i find the picture
of the house i tell mess more about this
then like my father is coming back from
his his you know going to erie and come
back late at night or whatever remember
he was like really sore and he had some
scratches on his hands and he was like
oh can you rub my back with ben gay and
stuff and i was like okay that's super
weird but okay
and he was like his muscles were all
sore and i was like this is really weird
i think he starts telling me about how
this is like january 20th 21st 1990 he
starts telling me how he's going to take
me down to florida for a medical
conference and my family every year
would go to these medical conferences
but he uh he's like i'm going to take
you to this medical conference and
that's when i came to school the next
day i said you need to call dave
messmore
he shows up at the place and i say dave
i said um uh my father wants to take me
to florida for a medical conference
dave i have been able to swim since i
was four years old
i'm going to drown in the gulf of mexico
you need to get me fuck out of my house
i mean i don't think i use the word fuck
but
i need to get out of my house and he
realized that like literally this is the
only witness to a potential murder and
this guy's going to kill a son and my
dad
100 was going to do that like randomly
like oh and now all these clues and i'm
feeling this and you're talking so on
the morning of january 24th 1990 i woke
up at 6 00 a.m to these two strangers in
my room and they're literally like
you have 20 minutes to pack a bag and
your things we're leaving was your dad
there at the house when they showed up
my father was gone already he was up in
eerie my grandmother was hysterical my
sister the yank and basically as they're
moving against the house the entire
house is full of cops guys and you know
crime lab guys and white coats all these
devices looking for i mean it was
it was full on how far is erie
pennsylvania from mansfield about four
and a half five hours okay it's it's a
waze all right
so
that night i go to so i go to a foster
home
um and that night i have like the worst
asthma attack in my life like i'm
thinking i'm going to die
they take me to the hospital in the
morning and i go and i see a doctor
friend who was friends with my mother
and father and all this and he gave me a
breathing treatment and things like that
and then and i was weird because as they
took me in the hospital they ushered me
past like the honor boxes if you
remember those for those of you who
actually read newspapers back in the day
um and they like turned me as we were
walking past it like turn me and i noted
that and i was like fucking motherfucker
and
then they sat down and they said you
know i got the reading screen calm down
okay he's all right there they go
so call your you know we have something
to tell you
lieutenant messmore found your mother
and then there was like this
it's like this really long fucking pause
which was of course not a long pause
it's long drawn out pause and i remember
i was looking at like an electrical
outlet
because i knew it was coming
and she says and i but i had this like
fucking like small little spark of hope
in my eyes
or my myself i was like
maybe this is gonna turn out okay maybe
and then she says and then and she was
dead
and the first thing that i said
was that bastard
first thing came out of my mouth you
knew
well the other thing is you knew before
but it wasn't reality until he spoke
those words and it still resonates with
you obviously yeah yeah i mean 33 years
later i mean it's your mom
you know we get one
yeah 32 years
and change yeah does this so this was
january 25th 1990.
and that's just when like
i mean i was already like man on fire
but that's
that was like oh
gloves are off this is a fucking street
fight
and
i
i had no idea how fucking
how
difficult the shit was about ready to
get but that's when shit got real
so
i um i was in
i i was in the foster care system
and
the thing is is that my mother's side
the family didn't want anything to do
with me because i looked like my father
literally what they said to me verbatim
my father's side of the family didn't
want anything to do with me because well
you put your
grandfather
literally went and testified in front of
the grand jury secured his indictment i
remember the woman who was in charge of
the grand jury used to be the principal
at my school and she i just remember her
saying after like your mother would be
so proud of you and then like it's the
whole like
case and it's just
months
drawn out and
you know i had talked to dave mesmore
several times and i had you know
developed a real rapport with him
because like he was sort of my saving
grace right he's the only person to
believe me the cop was the hero he was
the fucking hero man the cop was a hero
and
you know it was
you know
i was it was like five months of just me
in foster care and just like
what the fuck is gonna happen to my life
where am i going and the foster care
situation was not good that's tough it
is you know for any kid that's in the
system it's tough i have no family and i
have the one person that was my support
system in the world was dead she ain't
coming back right
and i remember did your sister end up
there as well my sister was there in
foster care with me and the people who
would take us into foster care they
wanted my sister they didn't want me
so that was their job we always wanted
to get my my mother was trying to help
them get a baby from taiwan and so then
they were like oh but we really have
they used to babysit her all the time
so they were like primed to do that
that's why they took us um
and
over that five months and i remember
like i talked to the prosecutors and
everything they were like you know you
don't need to testify
i'm like
wait this is where it fucking ends this
is a fucking battlefield man are you
kidding me like i mean i don't mean to
equate it to war but like it is war it's
like you know it's like me my father
with his team of fucking lawyers and me
and there's no evidence like there i
mean there's evidence it's all
circumstantial
and dave must was like you know you
don't have to testify like everybody's
like because everybody
everyone's reaction to the case is like
i can't believe they made you testify
i'm like nah don't get it twisted they
they were like you don't have to testify
you wanted to and i'm like you're
fucking out of your minds like they're
over my dead body i'm not testifying
like i am going to make sure that i do
my best for justice for my mother like
like you know there's like something
that's really crazy that i read like
somebody sent me on instagram a couple
weeks ago so people who have been
through like uh like
seemingly like defied seemingly
insurmountable odds have been through
such extreme tragedy have a fire inside
them that is almost
inextinguishable and that is a hundred
percent right and it's driven me ever
since then still to this day no i it's
you have to have it you know because you
either i mean to get emotional no you're
gonna do it as we said it's your mom man
but it's
you have to i mean and you know you hear
the old fighter flight you know that
that type of thing but it's like
you you have to be that strong you're
being it for yourself and for your mom
yeah you know and that's the big part
about it is you have to do it for her
and you yourself
obviously have to battle demons it's
tough you know as an 11 year old kid
for any kid any adult losing your mom
and that that's a shitty thing
at for any reason you know natural
causes it's tough as an 11 year old kid
for that type of reason
uh is
a thousand times worse but just like you
said you have to have this fire this
drive in there for her yeah
well then i'm going to make this comment
too
i can't the energy you have now now and
it takes one to know one i can't imagine
how much energy has a 11 year old i
can't i can't imagine how focused you
were on this because my mind works
similarly so
when you got on the stand and you
started talking you're very articulate
now i assume that you are articulate
thin and you got your point across
very well i mean
here's the thing is like
education was both my parents went to
penn and they were not they they went to
penn they were street kids from
philadelphia they're from poor you know
lower middle class families you know or
upper lower class families they didn't
come from money but they got in because
education education was like a big deal
like i was the kid that when when school
would end
got a week to fuck off and then you go
to summer school and go to art classes
and my mother was very involved in my
education as her father was with her
education and my father was very
educated he had four my father was
arrested he still had like he had 14
years of education under his belt he was
still paying off his student loans like
you know because he just he was like
they were very hungry for knowledge and
so like i was the last person on the
block to get the nintendo i just got in
that the year for christmas my mom
really bought it in front of me and said
you're not getting this till christmas
like
it was not like something duck hunt had
a
wedding had
so
the thing is is that like i have a
really sharp memory like i don't know
where i get it from i just remember
details and i think that what it was is
that my father did not realize that i
was literally their son and i remembered
every detail so i think i maybe i
testified for a day and a half it was
either a day and a half or two and a
half days i say sometimes two and a half
days it might have been a day and a half
anyways
i and i just remember like sitting on
that witness stand
and he wouldn't look at me and i'm just
like staring him down like a fucking
gangster like yeah motherfucker like
you're going to like i'm here like this
is us we are squaring off right here you
have abused me my entire life and now
you have killed the one fucking person
in my life that i love more than life
itself
you have taken that from me and you've
destroyed my entire family
it's fucking payback time and and it's
and i and i was so good at remembering
every single detail because on
cross-examination
they were grilling me and my i didn't
falter like there was you couldn't poke
holes in my story because as i tell
everyone the easiest thing to remember
in life is the fucking truth that's i'll
just say you can't poke holes if you're
telling the truth you're not going to
waver or like oh you know there was all
this stuff like oh you were coached on
the witness saying it was clear because
you were so confident i'm like i'm like
motherfucker like yeah i was i was
confident of the witness because i'm
telling the truth and i was you were
there and i was there like i'm telling
the truth
did maybe like some detail get skewed oh
i thought it was 318 it might have been
three o'clock okay sure there all these
okay whatever those are like
that's defense attorneys just that's
that's what you're trying to like shove
down my throat the fact and i remember
correcting the defense lawyers like no
you're not gonna say like i was just
like when i watched a murder in
mansfield on the big screen in new york
city when it premiered i was like i had
never seen the trial tapes i was like oh
my god i have not changed it's i'm just
older yeah i'm the same kid i have the
same manners always the same sardonic
sense of humor that i got from my mother
so i have two blue eyes a couple new
tattoos probably didn't have those 11.
but i'm like snarky with the prosecutor
with the defense attorneys i'm like
mocking my father look who's here it's
sherry just because that was what he did
yeah and it's like you know and people
were laughing in the courtroom but it
wasn't doing it for attention i was
doing it to be like
i'm like fuck this guy like you're not
going to get away with this and if you
do because this is the thing that people
don't understand and some people try to
like say oh you're you know when i talk
about this i'm profiting off my mother's
no motherfucker this happened to me
right this is
the
do you know how fucking hard it is to go
against your entire family and stand up
for what's right versus what you what is
comfortable or what is what a little kid
would do no i had to be a fucking man
from age 11 on and the thing is is that
i'm literally saying this and it's
knowing full well that if my father
wins with his
defense team that he's got
my life is over my life is already over
it's already done anyway
or i'm going he's going to get acquitted
i'm going to go back to his custody and
he's going to make the rest of my life a
living hell or i'm going to be la or i'm
going to be found in a ditch somewhere
like that's it like those are my two
options and they both fucking suck but
at least i know and i sit here today
knowing i told the truth i did what was
right and i didn't fucking back down
well the person responsible for
obviously your mom's life altering your
life is held accountable and
we've got probably a little less than 10
minutes here collier but sorry i didn't
mean to get so high oh dude this is
fantastic but we all know the details
yeah we know the details so the details
of uh and obviously listen man i mean i
know it it's still tough like you said
for you at 44 years old to talk about
and i understand that uh but that the
details on how the case
you know what the thing was that turned
this thing around all of a sudden we're
going to make an arrest how they found
your mom where they found your mom sure
so where where it where it turned was
not only what i said in the fact that
they couldn't turn up like my father
would tell them something and i'm like
no that's bullshit because she wouldn't
have gone there like so my father you
know had his lawyers dealing with the
cops and whatever he said then messwear
would be like
would your mom have gone to toronto by
herself i'm like no would you rather
like no she wouldn't have done that no
she wouldn't have thrown her credit
cards at him my father's story was like
she came down threw credit cards at him
and got in a car at the end of the
driveway and left and i'm like are you
fucking kidding like that's your fuck
that's the story we're going with bro
and he says it in court yeah and of
course it's a different story when i
confront him in a murder in mansfield
but there was that the house was the big
turning point and then the fact that my
father wanted to take me out of town on
a that the house in erie pennsylvania
pennsylvania because that was it so you
know this is 1990 there's no google
there's no zillow it's not easy to find
this stuff and that's when they found
that my father had bought a house tried
to get it for cash wanted for cash to
try to get in quicker asked to move in a
month earlier asked about lowering the
basement floor because they contacted
the realtor this is how they figured all
this out and that was when they're like
okay that's super fucking fishy and then
they're asking me about like did your
father talk about this house i was like
no i'm like i don't know this house
other than what is in his truck and that
it's his girlfriend in front of this
fireplace i'm like they're both
polaroids they're together and clearly
it's the same thing
and
when i would poke stool holes and
whatever his story was so what happened
is is that i'm taken into foster care
i'm having that asthma attack like i
said at night
at the same time while i'm having this
they literally they go into the house
they so
david mesmore gets cooperation with erie
pd you know like across across state
lines right that's not an easy thing
you're a cop absolutely it's difficult
and already his captain captain karns
has said
if you don't if this comes up cold
you're done like that's it like we're
screwed this guy's gonna sue us for
everything
again he's like this fucking kid won't
leave me alone i'll take my chances with
you captain i will take my chances with
this kid right right because he i was so
convincing because i'm so pale as i am
now i'm the same person and the thing is
is that
they go into the basement and
they're trying to figure they're looking
through the house like they're not
finding anything
and
what happened was is
oh okay i had told them about my father
purchasing some astroturf like indoor
outdoor carpeting the green you know the
green shit whatever yeah and it was on
our porch for a while and some tarps and
things that were at the house and i told
him they were on our porch i told
messmore this
so when they went downstairs they saw
this green astroturf carpeting
and they're looking around they're
looking around they're like fuck i don't
know and then they're like they smelled
like sort of a weird odor but they're
like i don't know and then they point
the flashlight on the wall and they see
a couple splatters of what they think is
cement and they're like
get the fucking shovels
they rip everything up because there
were shelves built and everything just
newly painted shelves and so it had this
weird sort of odor but everything was
painted and this is the basement of the
new house in here pennsylvania house the
one that i found the photo of
and they rip up the carpeting
they dig through
and then
oh yeah i mean they find they lift it up
and they see a grave and then they dig
it up and they pull their body out and
they're like
she's got a plastic bag tied around her
neck and the whole thing so my mother
was suffocated and bludgeoned to death
in the back of her head and then driven
from mansfield ohio to erie to this new
house your father bought
cut up some concrete
dropped her in it put it and then try to
cover it up
and what conveniently happened sorry is
the girlfriend i was just going to ask
was she aware of this was she involved
uncle who was partnering with my father
on this new business in erie
pennsylvania had conveniently found some
leftover concrete dumped on his property
and called the police about it so he had
like a little farm property or some
acreage i do remember that i don't know
if this happened i don't know you know
look there are many people have these
conspiracy theories about all of them
being involved and different things like
that and
i could guess i could go down that
rabbit hole if i want but like at the
end of the day my father caused my
mother's murder absolutely no yeah and
committed my mother's murder like
there's no doubt in my mind did the
and if i remember correctly correct me
if i'm wrong and i'm just going off this
sure one of the few episodes of forensic
files because it's about the forensics
the concrete splatter that you talked
about on the wall yes
or even the concrete that was used to
you know
cut up you know and replace with and the
concrete that was dumped out on this
property
they all matched up i remember there was
some forensic deal that was done where
they were able to compare the chemicals
or however these things were made
they all made it matched up i do
remember all circumstances so they might
they found the credit card receipts for
the tarp and the and the astroturf which
had been on our porch for a hot minute i
mean it was purchased
months before he emerged so this wasn't
a crime of passion no this was not a
crime of passion and that's the thing
when people watch the murderer man stuff
they don't get they're like oh yeah so
he killed her and i was like no this was
like this was premeditated
that's what aggravated murder is is is
premeditated that's what they call it in
ohio at the time it's premeditated so
like he bought the house asked about
lowering the basement floor asked about
like all these things months in advance
bought the tour rented a jackhammer to
like my father didn't do labor yeah you
know but he had done construction
growing up in philadelphia while he was
in school
and um because our italian family had a
construction business so there was like
all this stuff
and
you know he um and he's super sore and
he has all these marks and everything
and it's like
you know my father was
not the most common sense person as far
as like what he does
you know could fix it couldn't hardly
screw in a light bulb but like when
you're trying to like hire that shit and
you're like in that zone oh yeah you can
do anything for sure oh yeah when you're
on covered coverage
circumstantial evidence and i was able
to tie in all of that circumstantial
evidence in a time frame
on without me knowing like they're what
their time frame was so everything i
told it just all lined up because i was
telling the truth what what a concept
what a concept what a concept all right
collier we got two minutes
this is a fascinating story you've
talked to your dad
since then i in the film yeah i confront
him um and he is you know he's a
sociopath and he is in denial of his
guilt and i'll just tell you real fast
like when i pitched the idea to to the
department of corrections because they
they wouldn't let us come in i was like
look i was like this is an opportunity
for my father
to admit what he's done and we will have
this big come to jesus moment it'll be
great so they thought it was going to be
this big thing and they had their
photographer there and all this stuff i
didn't tell them that i also know my
father's a sociopath because my father
thought that i was going with with my
friend john morrison all these people to
make a film to help him get out of
prison so when he comes in the room in
the film he has a smile on his face and
then i pull out this letter that he had
sent back to me when i was 13 years old
because here's the thing i got into the
film business and i did everything i did
because i wanted to fucking have an
answer on why you murdered my mother i
had written him a letter when i was 13
years old and i asked him to please come
clean about murdering my mother why are
you putting everybody through this
putting your girlfriend through with
sherry at the time your daughter who
just my father had a daughter you know
was born 12 days before he was arrested
so i had a half sister uh why all our
whole family i was like just tell me the
truth i'm just pleading with you to tell
me the truth
and he he opened the letter read it
wrote refuse and returned to sender and
sent it back to me and i read him that
letter in prison right there in front of
him and i say why did you send that
and it's just all downhill for me as
soon as i pulled that letter out and i
told him i was like i've had these
questions ever since you murdered my
mother the whole game changes his whole
demeanor drive and then it's just an
hour of conversation he's just
completely in denial all these stories
which don't match up it's just it's
insane so one last question collier so
if i understand it he still fucking
denies doing this yes so
that's absolutely well
he says that she came at him with a
knife he pushed her it happened
downstairs she hit her head on this
furniture
and that he panicked i was like well you
know suffocation it was the primary
cause of death i was like how did she
get the plastic bag over her head oh i
put her the plastic bag overhead i was
like why did you do that oh because i
didn't want to look at her
yeah while you're a strangler you don't
want to look at her like you know what i
mean it's just
just like you said narcissist and
sociopaths and sociopathy and it's it's
it's a real it's a real thing all right
carly before we wrap this up man how can
everybody uh
follow you find your podcast find you on
the gram whether they're trying to date
you i want to hear your stories hashtag
blue eyes yeah
so my instagram and all my social media
handles are all at collier landry uh the
podcast that i do is called moving past
murder um you can find that at call your
landry dot com forward slash podcast i'm
on apple spotify i also have a youtube
channel youtube.com forward slash call
your landry where i have all the
episodes i release new episodes every
single friday i talk to cool people like
yourselves and like chris hanson who i
just interviewed tara newell from dirty
john cara robinson chamberlain yeah like
some dope people then i also read my
father's letters from prison which
really helps people because i have 500
of them over 30 years and i open a new
letter randomly and i just read it for
the first time live and it's really cool
and it helps people understand oh it
probably helps even yourself you know in
a way that's cool all right call
everybody we do appreciate it man it's
great running into you here at crime con
salute
[Music]
you